a uh an indented face of Joe Biden has
triggered medical disclosures and we
have now learned that Joe Biden is using
a CPAP machine not CPAC very different
thing a CPAP machine at night to treat
sleep apnea you know the the images that
came out
it's not even really that clear but if
you look at the image I have up on the
screen if you look at Joe Biden's right
cheek there are these two parallel lines
it's sort of an indent if you trace a
line between his earlobe to the sort of
upper lip you see one of those lines and
then maybe about half to three quarters
of an inch below that you see another
parallel line an indentation of sorts
this has now triggered a release from
the White House about Joe Biden's Health
Joe Biden reports CNN has started using
a CPAP machine to treat sleep apnea
after indentations from straps were seen
on both sides of his face yesterday
Wednesday morning White House spokesman
Andrew Bates says quote since 2008 the
president has disclosed his history with
sleep apnea in medical reports he used
the CPAP machine last night which is
common for people with that history an
official familiar with the matter said
Biden started using the device in recent
weeks to improve sleep quality
um Biden has had a history of sleep
apnea in the past sleep apnea is a sleep
disorder in which breathing repeatedly
stops and starts about 30 million people
in the United States have sleep apnea
that's uh close to 10 percent so what is
a CPAP machine a CPAP CPAP stands for
continuous positive airway pressure it's
a machine that helps people with sleep
apnea breathe more regularly and uh
consistently while they are sleeping to
prevent those stops and starts of
breathing by delivering a steady flow of
pressurized air
you wear a mask I know a couple of
people that have this now some people
wrote to me and said David you know
sleep apnea can cause cognitive decline
uh this may explain what's going on with
Joe Biden it's really not so much
cognitive decline but it is true that
sleep apnea if not controlled can affect
cognitive function by virtue of the fact
that you are not resting well if you
regularly stop breathing and have these
stops and starts of breathing while you
are sleeping it affects quality of sleep
quality of sleep can affect cognition
and memory and all of those different
things and there are some studies that
show that sleep disordered breathing of
which sleep apnea is one kind
uh makes you roughly 26 more likely to
develop a cognitive impairment of some
kind versus those who don't have sleep
disordered breathing so is this like a
huge deal uh no I don't think it's a
huge deal this is not a new disclosure
it's just an explanation as to why on
this particular day yesterday Joe Biden
had these marks we don't have to I mean
listen we don't have to pretend that Joe
Biden is the epitome of Youth Vigor and
energy to recognize that there have been
a lot of correct things done under Biden
and that given the opportunity to have
either Joe Biden for four more years or
Donald Trump back for four more years or
Ron DeSantis or whatever that I would
still pick Joe Biden it's not you know I
get emails from people on the right
first of all saying you'll never talk
about XYZ thing with Biden like this why
not I'm talking about it there's really
no problem if I don't hide things from
my audience that's number one but then
number two okay so Joe Biden is sleep
apnea and wears a CPAP machine and he's
80 and he's tripped a couple of times
you think that means I'm gonna elect the
guy who wanted to Nuke a hurricane and
uh is accused of quite literally dozens
and dozens of crimes and did all of the
things that Trump did of course and I'm
still going to vote for Joe Biden okay
Biden's old and he doesn't have as much
energy and vigor as he did when he was
uh first Joe Biden uh Barack Obama's
vice president for example so what what
like what what's the big gotcha there
it's not really a big shocker
um so listen I'll keep you apprised of
Joe Biden's health and uh at this point
in time particularly based on the
economic record it seems pretty clear
who we're better off having for another
four years if the choices are Trump or
Biden uh or de Sanctus and Biden if you
disagree with me let me know and I know
many people do and I'm perfectly
comfortable with that